Speaker 1: All right. Extremely strange news
out of the Alex Jones defamation trial. As
many of you know, the jury found for the
plaintiffs in the Alex Jones defamation trial
of roughly $49 million. Alex Jones text messages
that were obtained by plaintiff's attorney Mark
Bankston during that trial have now been turned
over to the House committee investigating the
January six Trump riots. And the story is
going to shift over there to some degree,
but there's now a new wrinkle to the case. Marc
Bankston, the attorney for the plaintiffs who
will hopefully be joining me on the show very
soon to talk about all of the all of the trial
he revealed to our friend Anna Caspary in On
the Young Turks that Alex Jones sent what appear
to be nonconsensual, consensual and sexual
non-consensual nude images of his own wife
to Roger Stone, the indicted and pardoned
former Trump adviser. This is now going from
just horrifying to bizarre. Look at this in The
Guardian. The headline is Alex Jones Sent Nude
Photo of Wife to Roger Stone. Sandy Hook Lawyer
Reveals Picture was among a cache of messages
inadvertently handed over by Infowars host's
lawyer to the opposition legal team. Remember
this incredible moment from the trial where
it was revealed that Alex Jones own attorney
accidentally sent a digital copy of his
entire phone to the opposing counsel.
Lawyers for the notorious American conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones accidentally gave his legal
adversaries a nude photo of his wife that he had
texted to the conservative political operative,
Roger Stone. The seemingly farcical, I
would call it farcical or Kafkaesque,
the seemingly farcical but entirely true
development was the latest bit of fallout
since one of the attorneys for a family suing
Jones for defamation revealed last week that Jones
own lawyer inadvertently handed over numerous text
messages. The lawyer, Mark Bankston, the recipient
of the leak, appeared on Monday on the Young
Turks to confirm one of the texting questions
contained a naked photo of Jones wife sent to
Stone. Now, since there's been a commentary
from Alex Jones wife, Alex Jones wife says
she is unaware and upset. Her husband sent
a nude photo of her to Roger Stone. So indeed
it was sent nonconsensual. What we don't know
is whether the picture itself was non-consensual.
There's a little bit of a gray area. Alex Jones
might have taken the picture consensually
and sent it to Roger Stone without consent,
or even the existence of the picture itself might
be non-consensual. Let's take a listen to the clip
from Mark Bankston speaking to the Young Turks.
Speaker 2: Mr. Jones said that there was an
intimate photo of his wife on the phone.
That I can also confirm. That's true,
and I normally wouldn't talk about that in public.
But there is a public interest angle into this is
that I'm a little concerned about it because
that intimate photo was sent to Roger Stone.
And I don't know if that was consensual and if
it wasn't consensual, and Mrs. Wolf Jones should
know about that. And there might be something
that needs to be done about that. And again,
it can be totally consensual. But when I see
that and I don't see any indication that it was,
I'm concerned something might not
be on the up and up, that there are
certainly laws in certain states about that.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And in fact, we've since found
out, thanks to the comment from Erica Wolf Jones,
she was not aware of the exchange and was upset
about the disclosure. The wife of conservative
radio host Alex Jones told Insider Tuesday she
was unaware her husband sent a nude photo of her
former of her to former Donald Trump adviser Roger
Stone. We're going to try to get Mark Bankston
on the show very, very soon to talk about.
I think that there are probably a dozen
other bizarre, major, interesting stories
underneath what is currently publicly known about
this. And it's so strange to think I've told the
story before. Back when I met Alex Jones years ago
at a talk radio event called The Talkers New Media
Seminar. He really first of all, his physical
appearance was far more normal. He also
spoke far more normally in what was not like an on
air capacity. He was still the wacky guy on air.
But behind the scenes, we were just chatting and
I was on the outskirts of this small group of
four people who were who were
chatting. I had not met him before.
He seemed to even acknowledge the way that he
is perceived, saying after the speech he gave,
you know, I could have really freaked him out if
I had wanted to sort of like acknowledging that
he toned down his character because it was
sort of like an industry event or whatever.
Now, every video of Alex Jones outside of
his show, whether it's someone going up to
him on the street or the testimony that he gave
under oath during the trial that just completed,
it seems as though there is now really no
difference between the on air Alex Jones and
the affair Alex Jones And it is dramatically
different than what I experienced personally.
I mean, I guess at this point it was like 12 years
ago. So I don't know what to make of it, but it
wouldn't come as a shock if indeed there was this
predatory aspect to Alex Jones as well, where he
is non-consensual, sending nude pictures of his
wife to people, all extraordinarily bizarre.